the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so professor Gossard gave the lecture
last week I'm going to pick up where he
left off but let's talk about the
concept questions from the from the
homework you've been working on so the
first one is our cart you expect to be
able to eliminate the terms involving
gravity in the equations of motion by
choosing coordinates with respect to the
static equilibrium position so we've
talked about that and this this one does
the restoring force on the pendulum what
makes it come back to you know to zero
after its damped out and hang straight
down what gravity does that gravity term
varies with the the torque that the
gravity puts around the pivot is mg L
over 2 sine theta so the gravity term is
involved with the motion variable theta
so this case gravity is going to be
involved in the natural frequency and in
the equations of motion no matter what
so you'll will you will not be able to
eliminate their gravity terms next this
one this is a vibration isolation
question will the addition of damping
increase or reduce the vibration of the
table in response to the floor motion at
30 Hertz so I guess this depends on what
the natural frequency of the system is
but we're trying to do vibration
isolation and presuming if you read the
problem you're supposed to find a sort
of stiffness such that you can reduce
the response of the table by 12 dB I
think it said from the wrist motion of
the floor so that's something
substantially less than one and you will
be out the this one takes a best
describe with a picture
the transfer function for response of
the floor response of the table over the
motion of the floor the magnitude of
that transfer function that's just the
ratio of X to Y that looks like this if
the damping is zero and as you add
damping all points cross right here this
little if some damping ring does that
more damping does this and in order to
accomplish the what's been described
this is one point o here if you're
trying to get make this table respond
less than the floor you must be
somewhere out here where you're below
one so this is omega over Omega N and
right here at resonance you're at 1.0 so
this is some you know a 2 or 3 or 4 for
this value out here let's say here's
where you find the answer to be and
without damping you're there and that's
12 DB down if you add damping it pushes
you up these curves does that make the
risk is that that make the response
larger the undesirable response the
motional table larger or smaller as you
add damping at that operating point
increases it right okay so in this case
we'll the addition to damping increase
to reduce the vibration it'll increase
it but damping is a necessary evil you
need you need some damping in the system
so it doesn't if you bump it it doesn't
sit there and oscillate all day long
next okay this is a platform do you
think I could actually do it did you
read this so this is a Coast Guard light
station off of Cuttyhunk down in off of
Woods Hole basically is doing this in
time with the motion of a platform
resonance is a wonderful thing if you
can make the force be right at the
natural frequency of the structure it
actually doesn't take a lot of force to
drive the amplitude to pretty large
if the damping's small so I think the
damping in this case is about 1% and
that means the amplification a dynamic
amplification 1 over 2 Zeta is about 50
so I actually could do this this is a
true story
ok next for small motions about the
horizontal you expect a natural
frequency to be a function of gravity so
so this is on some of you about equal
yes now when it's just horizontal the
torque that gravity provides is some mg
pulling down on the disks it
center of mass somewhere in that body
not at the pivot but let's say it's some
distance a away so the torque that
gravity the restoring torque is be some
mg cross R cross mg mg R if R is a
distance and that's a torque and that
length of that moment arm might vary
it's going to vary like cosine theta
around horizontal and if they tis and
what's for small angles what's the
cosine goes to 1 so you find out that
this just looks like mg R it's or small
angles of vibration and you can in fact
get it out of it doesn't enter into the
equation for the natural frequency so
natural frequency thing won't be a
function of gravity because of this its
small angle vibration around a
horizontal point okay when will the
acceleration system is 1/2 that required
to make the mass slide what's the
magnitude of the friction force so
friction is one of those things that
it's only as big as you need it to be so
if the largest friction that this thing
can sustain is in fact mu mg answer a
but F equals MA if the acceleration is
half of what is required to have that
thing be just slip it will just slip
when it you when you are at 8th wave a
force which is mu mg
and so that force is equal to mass times
acceleration the acceleration then you
can figure out what that will be just
when it slips but now if you reduce
acceleration to half that the friction
force required to keep it in place is
only half as big and it will be that
friction force and it'll be half of mu
mg so it's actually B and X is that it
no okay this is a simple but actually
sometimes hard to see through question
what initial conditions will be required
this this problem can be solved by
initial conditions is it mortar launches
this shell and the trick to this
question key to this question
it's the for your mathematical model of
the system your equation of motion is
write the equation of motion without the
shell because once it shoots this thing
the shell is gone and it's vibrating
it's now system without that 25 kilogram
mortar shell part of the system is gone
now it's just the mass of the system
without the mortar shell needed and
there are two initial conditions that
then you can say well that when you shot
the motor set the shell that was a
certain amount of momentum and from
conservation of momentum you can figure
out what the momentum of the the main
mass has to be equal and opposite to the
shell you shot so that gives you an
initial velocity but there's also an
initial displacement in this problem so
that's the key to figuring this out so
what initial conditions would be
required and at C both an initial
velocity and an initial displacement but
the key is to make your mathematical
model about the system without the shell
okay good got it all right
so today we're going to pick up where
professor Gossard left off but I'm also
going to do a bit of a summary right now
about vibration and modeling the
different kinds of systems that we talk
about we talk about vibration they vary
from simple single degree of freedom
Massa leaders like a simple pendulum one
degree of freedom to continuous system
beams and vibrate and so I'm going to
try to give you this sort of an overview
of vibration to sort of give you a
little understanding embryo a map of
information kind of let you know what
the body of vibration analysis looks is
and what part of it that will have a
chance we're having we're covering in
this course so I think I will it's a
little more bored
so we classify dynamics problems into
for convenience rigid bodies rigid body
dynamics and flexible bodies one way to
think of and this course is basically
about rigid body dynamics and under this
we then have two categories that are
convenient single degree of freedom
systems and multiple degree of freedom
systems for the purposes of energy
talking about vibration single degree of
freedom systems have one equation of
motion and if they vibrate they have and
if I'll put over here
if vibration occurs then you have one
natural frequency and mode it's it's
sort of silly to talk about mode shape
for a single degree freedom system
because it's only relative to itself so
one natural frequency in one sort of
degenerate mode shape multiple degree of
freedom systems have n equations of
motion for the number of degrees of
freedom and if they vibrate they have n
Omega eyes or nm n values of Omega I for
I equals 1 to n you get n natural
frequencies of the system and you will
get
fit in mode shapes so an N degree of
freedom this is equal to the number of
degrees of freedom an N degree of
freedom system will have n natural
frequencies and n mode shapes that go
along with it
now what about what about flexible
bodies so a string taut string like a
guitar string this and actually I should
say over here these rigid body things we
have found what kind of equations of
motion these are ordinary differential
equations and there's a finite number of
them so forth the flexible bodies like
taut strings have are described by
partial differential equations
the number of degrees of freedom ends
here is the number of degrees of freedom
actually goes to infinity and you get an
infinite number of Omega eyes the
natural frequencies and an infinite
number of corresponding mode shapes so
just you know just about everything in
the world can be made to vibrate so how
do you so how do you tell if a you know
you've written you've got a mechanical
system a rigid body has got three
degrees of freedom how do you know
whether or not it's going to vibrate it
will exhibit vibration well one thing
you could do is figure out all the
equations of motion and solve them and
see if cosine Omega T is a solution
right that's kind of a hard way the
other way does it go up to it and give
it a smack and see if it vibrates that's
the simple way okay if you have the
mechanical system just give it a whack
and if it oscillates around some stable
equilibrium position it exhibits
vibration so this is a flexible system
you can actually probably see this from
an area just by giving this frame a
smack and sit there and vibrate and it
has it at some natural frequency but
that's a continuous system the this
continuously improving little demo so
professor Gossard for his lecture last
week had done this really neat
embellishment which allows you to figure
out and excite the two different natural
modes but this system you have equations
of motion for it you could write it and
if you come up and give it a whack it
oscillates and you could also find out
that sure enough cosine Omega T sine
Omega T
solutions to the equations of motion so
systems that vibrate are things are
systems that oscillate about static
equilibrium positions and another way
you can say that it's when mechanical
vibration occurs is always an exchange
of energy between kinetic and potential
attic and potential so our pendulum it
goes when it reaches zero velocity up
here it's all potential energy reaches
maximum velocity down here it's all
kinetic it goes back and forth there's a
sloshes back and forth the energy system
from kinetic to potential and back in
all vibration has that property okay so
that scented some basic properties of
vibration now yes it's all the way
there's a lot of there's a whole body of
knowledge about vibration and we choose
or for the purposes of this class we
choose to break it down into two kinds
of vibration and one is what we call
free vibration and that we've learned
already his response but only response
is a response to initial conditions and
what we call forced vibration
now forces can come of all kinds and we
for the purposes of this this course we
look at a particular kind of force so we
focus on harmonic excitation so
excitation that looks like is of the
form cosine Omega T or e to the I Omega
T these are these these are external
excitations
so we've choose to break down the
analysis of the vibration of systems
into response to initial conditions
called free vibration no external forces
and forced vibration but we focus on a
particular kind harmonic and we go up in
one step further and say we're only just
we're going only going to study steady
state then steady state means you've
waited a long time turned it on let it
shake for quite a while all the initial
startup transients have been damped out
and you're just left with the
steady-state vibration and that leads to
things like the transfer functions for
single degree freedom systems that we've
talked about okay now there's one other
breakdown subdivision that we need to
talk about and that is whether systems
are linear or non-linear
so let's answers all set up so you can
see it this is a double pendulum how
many degrees of freedom - okay and in
general the kinks equations of motion of
this thing are going to be nonlinear
right you know no the pendulum is we
just a simple pendulum is the restoring
torque is MGL sine
betta so you know it's got sine Thetas
and that and this one gets quite messy
and especially if you give it large
amplitudes and that really isn't
vibration it's not it's looping over
itself and then doing other things so
cosine Omega T is not a solution is not
a solution of this it's got to be more
complicated than that so when this thing
is exhibiting large motions it's the
equations of motion are completely
nonlinear and you're going to need a
computer to crank out the full solution
to that got to integrate these nonlinear
equations of motion but as the amplitude
settles down to something pretty small
it's on now it's vibrating about an
equilibrium position the equilibrium
position straight down and the damping
of it has made it such that the only
motion left is it's called its first
mode of vibration and so if we linearize
the equations of motion assuming small
amplitudes around static equilibrium
positions then we can then it then we
can find a vibration solution and work
it out by hand probably that's first
mode for this system and if I'm careful
I can they're second mode and for small
oscillations it has a very clear single
frequency that vibrates that the
amplitude decays of time because of
damping okay and for every natural
frequency there is a particular mode
shape that goes along with that natural
frequency the first one for this system
have to wait for this thing to damp out
now it's got a little mix of the two but
I think is it
the for the second natural frequency
motion dies out faster than the first
because it has more cycles per unit time
so it settles down this is now mostly
first mode vibration and you can see
that both are move both move in the same
direction the bottom one a little more
the top and that's the first mode it has
a unique natural frequency and a mode
shape that specific only - that goes
along with that natural frequency okay
so
so their final just further breakdown
here I'll call it
it's basically into non-linear and
linearized so in the in our discussions
of vibration in this course we basically
talk to only talked about this so we're
only doing
okay so that's that's quite a breakdown
you start at all possible vibration
systems rigid bodies single degree
freedom multi degree freedom but finite
number of degrees of freedom or
continuous they can have linear or
nonlinear equations of motion but if we
require them to be linear then we're and
that's what we're going to look at then
we sort of narrowed this down what we're
looking at to this so there's lots of
other things possible to look at like
that really nonlinear motion of that
two-dimensional thing but our study of
vibration is here this is what we're
doing at 2 W 3 but there's a lot of
important problems that are covered by
that lots of lots of real things in
nature that are problematic for
engineers a problematic for design can
be analyzed with linear equations of
motion and even if they're not linear if
you do the linear solution first it
gives you a starting point to think
about what's the behavior of the
nonlinear systems but this is our study
of vibration and we're going to do that
for and what we had started doing that
in two ways we look at the response to
initial conditions called free vibration
and we look at response steady-state
response of now these linear systems -
forced vibration and last week you
looked you were looking for the first
time or the professor Gossard Pleasant
lecture about the free vibration
response of a basically a two degree
freedom system so why it was a why do
two degree freedom systems well the
simplest next thing step up from single
degree and they're sort of
mathematically tractable you can do them
on paper we emphasize you know looking
at two degree freedom systems because we
do the math on the board do the math and
paper but as you get two more degrees of
freedom basically you're going to have
to do it's easier to do it using the
computer and in order to do that you
need to know some linear algebra so I'm
kind of curious what in terms of linear
algebra like multiplying two matrices
together or finding the determinant of a
matrix or inverting a matrix how many of
you or actually have had you know sort
of been taught that how many at may have
me perhaps haven't was it an eighty do
you do that in 1803 now is that where
you do it okay good so that's helpful I
wasn't here whether or not I can assume
that you at least that you know how know
what the determinant of a matrix is that
would be that's great that's really
helpful
okay let's talk so we want a linear
equations of motion and I've done a
little bit about linearization but not
much so let's talk a little bit about
that for a second for a pendulum
we know the equation of motion for
actually we could make this a more
complicated pendulum you know it could
be a stick or any rigid body swinging
about this point a we know that we can
write the equation of motion icz with
respect to a theta double dot plus MGL
we'll make L the distance here to the
wherever G is the MGL sine theta and for
free vibration that's all there is to it
and to linearize this equation we just
say well we know that sine theta is
equal to 1 theta minus theta cubed over
3 factorial plus theta to the fifth over
5 factorial and the cosine theta just to
have it available here is 1 minus theta
squared over 2 factorial so forth and
when we say linearize we really mean we
want our equations to involve the motion
variables at most to first order so the
first order term for scientists theta
there's no first order term for cosine
theta squared is data squared it's
nonlinear so the the small angle
approximation for cosine is it's
approximately 1 and 2 sine as it's
approximately theta for small motions
theta small so when we linearize this
equation we just substitute in for sine
theta it's linear approximation and we
get MGL theta so we've seen that one
many times and that's your linearized
equation of motion but now you've got
this week's homework and get a harder
problem and that's our cart
and here you have theta and an X are
your two equations equation didn't we
you've worked this probably for and you
know what the previous homeworks you've
gotten the equation of motion I'll write
one of them down here so one of the
equations of motion is this is M 1 M 2 K
B and this stick is a stick it's a long
G in the middle so the equation of
motion for this looks like m1 plus m2 X
double dot plus m2 L over 2 theta double
dot
- m 2l over to theta dot squared theta
and then plus BX dot plus KX and equals
and in fact this one has a force on it
it's equal to F of T now is that a
nonlinear equation
so this is the force equation mass times
acceleration or forces you know you got
another equation of motion here which is
the torque one this is just one of them
so is it linear' nonlinear how many v
how many think it's nonlinear okay what
and if I have by numbers of terms here
one two three four five and that's not a
motion that just doesn't involve motion
so if one through five which one's the
vidonne linear term three okay
so how do you linearize that thing yeah
in fact it's third order so the just the
reason I wanted to mention this today if
you haven't thought about being
confronted with linearization problems
before we're trying to linearize the
system so that we can by making it
linear we can make cosine Omega T a
solution right we want cosine Omega T to
be a solution to this thing so if you if
you let
so you've got a term that looks like M L
over m 2l over 2 theta dot squared theta
well theta in this problem some function
of time we're hoping we want to find a
solution that has some amplitude times
say a cosine Omega T and theta dot is
minus Omega theta naught sine Omega T
and so that expression up there the
magnitude of that expression or the
magnitude of theta dot squared theta is
proportional to you get a theta naught
here and you get it Omega squared theta
naught squared here so this term is
proportional to theta naught cubed and
if the angle theta is small then then a
small angle cubed is really small and so
the way you the way you linearize this
equation is to throw this out so you
throw if you when you've done all your
tricks you can like replacing theta sine
theta with theta and cosine theta with 1
and you still end up with terms that
have our two higher order than 1 in the
motion variable theta or X you throw it
out
and so if you throw that term out then
you end up with a nice linear equation
of motion
okay so now for the rest of today we're
going to talk about free vibration
solution so we're not going to worry for
the moment about the forced vibration
steady-state transfer function stuff
we're talking just about free vibration
and this is a linear equations of motion
okay
so vibration is a pretty big body of
knowledge and we've really we're doing
all that we're doing an introduction to
vibration about half a dozen lectures
here so there's lots of things that I'm
not going to have time to teach you but
there are a few things I really want you
to go away with understanding and one
one of these key concepts is that the
vibration of a multiple degree of
freedom system say this this is a two
degree of freedom system that the
vibration of this system the free
vibration can be made up of the su sum
of two parts and any any vibration of
the system at all so any arbitrary set
of initial conditions I give it let it
go this key concept is they responsibly
made up of two pieces vibration in each
of the two modes and if you can solve
the vibration that's in first mode first
mode the one where they're going to kind
of together second mode their opposite
one another that the total solution can
be made up a contribution for mode one
and a contribution for mode two okay so
this is this concept called mode
superposition it's really quite powerful
so you can figure out the response of
the first mode in the system figure out
the response of the second modes
contribution add them together and
that's the total solution and that this
this is this works this concept works
like it like there's all sorts of
caveats that one gets into but basically
this is true for all
lightly damped systems get into heavy
damping and strange damping you have to
make some adjustments but for lightly
damped systems you'll find that this
concept of mode superposition works out
just fine so an illustration of this
ascent really simple illustration in
some ways easier than this one I don't
know if I can get this so you can see it
in the picture or not maybe not really
this is just to little lead weights this
is a double pendulum it has two natural
frequencies one is that one you see the
two weights go in the same direction
bottom weight a little bit more larger
angle than that it's in the top weight
and it's at a particular frequency and
that's the mode shape that goes through
this frequency so another key concept is
that for free vibration the total
solution is made up of the vibration the
free vibration of each mode and in each
mode has a particular frequency and a
particular shape to it so that's the
first mode frequency and the first mode
shape the second mode a little harder
time getting it started that looks like
that masses move in opposite directions
it's kind of rotating around where you
can't see it do it in the plane it's
hard to do here it doesn't want to
behave like it's confined to a plane
they're going in opposite directions and
the frequencies higher but the this
motion that mode shape is a fixed
feature of this mode of vibration along
with its natural frequency so this idea
of mode superposition ok and a second
concept here is that for
for free vibration of each mode it
so it oscillates at a unique frequency
for this two degree of freedom system
you have two natural frequencies Omega 1
and Omega 2 and for each at each Omega n
there is a corresponding mode shape so
any any vibration of a linear system
free vibration of it any vibration at
all is composed of a superposition of
the two modes part of this motions in
the first mode at its natural frequency
and in its shape and part of the motion
when I give a is has a second
contribution which is at the natural
frequency of the second mode and in its
shape so I'm going to give you a a quick
demo and ask you if see if you can use
what I just said to analyze a motion
so this is just a block on some strings
and I'm going to show you emotion and I
want you to tell me whether or not it
could possibly be a natural frequency
emotion at in one mode no or it's the
other answer is it's a it's the sum of
multiple modes but I'm going to show you
emotion and want you to tell me and
argue on the basis of what I've just
told you whether or not you are seeing a
single mode of vibration and use the
clamp here so I don't have to stand
there and hold it
okay I'm going to displace it so the way
you do free vibration you give it an
initial displacement some initial
conditions and let go so I'm going to
pull this over and back let go just
watch closely what you see it do
and this
all right now it's doing more way I want
it looks like going a circle right now
and that looks like it just going back
and forth on a diagonal and then it's
going to start circling the other way
it's going in a circle and now it goes
to on the diagonal left and right and
then it starts back into a circle again
are you observing a natural mode of
vibration
it looks like it's single frequency
right it looks like it's all happening
one that one frequency but is it a
natural mode one a unique natural mode
wants to make a case for whether it is
or isn't ok how many believe that it's
you're seeing a natural mode of
vibration no how many think you're not
seeing a natural mode of vibration see
if you're awake ok you know believe that
the natural mode you make the case
what's ary how do you use sort of this
definition of a natural mode to tell me
why this can't be
okay and that the evidence you see is
because what does it do okay so if it
circles around part of the time then
goes straight back and forth part of the
time is it a constant mode shape of
vibration no and there's the that's all
you need to observe if the thing doesn't
keep a constant single shape at a single
frequency it's not a natural mode so
let's take it let's do a different case
I flicked it just this way and ignore
that a little bit of torsion so just
going back and forth in line other than
slowly damping out that has just one
motion to it and it's at one natural
frequency so do you think that's a mode
that's probably is too and so is this
one and observe and ignore that high
frequencies back and forth it's just a
pendulum and it's just stays just
pendulum motion no circular around or
any of that so that's also a natural and
it occurs at a particular frequency so
these are two pennies are two individual
pendulum oceans one this way and one
that way and what I was doing at the
beginning is I pulled it to the side
which would start one of those modes and
I pulled it back which will put some
energy into the other mode and let it go
and now what you have is the sum of
these two different motions adding up to
go and it goes in circles and then
straight lines and the fact that they
this is a phenomenon called beading and
it is because these two pendulum
even though there have strings of the
same length
they actually have slightly different
natural frequencies you could at their
each single degree of freedom systems
are two independent single degree
freedom systems each with their own
natural frequency but if you mix them
then they're going to exhibit this
motion okay so that's something really
important to remember a quiz question
that I like to ask is it's easy to it's
easy to
a grade and it's no math required is to
literally I've often done this in exams
walk-in with something like that block
of wood and say you know is this a
natural mode okay that's time to do one
see here
okay
so now let's pick up where professor
Gossard left off just go to talking
about natural frequencies and mode
shapes of linearized
two degree of freedom systems but I want
to generalize a little bit of what he
did so he in his lecture analyzed this
system like this okay I'll just kind of
put the highlights here and this is now
solving for natural frequencies and mode
shapes you came up with a set of
equations of motion for this this was I
guess M 1 M 2 and the equations of
motion for this are M 1 in matrix form
now I'm going to do this to emphasize
something in general there could be
damping in our linearized system and we
have a stiffness matrix K 1 plus K 2
minus K 2 and in general there could be
forces which are functions of time on
that system now if we want to find
natural frequencies and mode shapes we
go looking for what we call the undamped
natural frequencies and mode shapes so
this problem doesn't even have dampers
in it but if it did for the purpose of
finding natural frequencies and mode
shapes you just set to 0 and with the
forces you do the same thing and now you
have undamped unforced equations of
motion and this is then of the form of
mass matrix times an acceleration vector
X 1 X 2 plus a stiffness matrix times a
displacement vector equals 0 so in
matrix notation looks like that and now
so in ghent this is the way you would do
any rigid body vibration problem it
could this is two degrees of freedom but
this is the general expression for an N
degree of freedom system and if we had
three masses here then you'd these would
be 3 by 3 matrices instead of two by
twos so that's the basic formulation and
you went through last time the 2 by 2
you can actually go through and find the
fourth order equation in omega and solve
for 2 roots of Omega squared and you got
the two natural frequencies plug
back in you got the two mode shapes to
go along with them so that was you did
it that way so you can by hand so that
you can see how you can work out the
natural frequencies so how can you do
I'm going to show you the more a
approach that you more likely use one a
computer and if you get to larger orders
and degree of freedom systems you're
going to want to do this instead of by
hand have a computer do the work for you
so listen let's this is the generic form
let's just assume for a minute
it's an N degree of freedom system so
these are n by n matrices how would we
find the natural frequencies and mode
shapes of this general system so you
assume to assume solutions of the form
of what I've been describing in natural
mode any natural mode of the system has
a particular shape to it and a
particular frequency and that's the key
that's the key assumption here you some
solutions of the form that this vector X
I'm going to instead of writing the
brackets like this I'll just I'm going
to make this so X here is just with a
line underneath it so X is of the form
you know it's x1 of T down to X n if you
have n degrees of freedom you're looking
for a solution for that thing and it's
going to have an amplitude to it a 1
down to a n and in it this is any one
mode so any one mode will look like a
set of amplitudes that govern its
mode shape and it will oscillate we can
write the oscillation as cosine Omega
now put an eye here it's the I
thoroughly Qin C minus some phase angles
so in general each mode some solutions
I'll say here for each mode so each mode
the any mode mode I will look like this
it'll have a shape to it governed by
this and these are basically in
constants once determined this is just a
constant and here is your time
dependence and it's going to left out my
T
it's going to oscillate at some natural
frequency so we know this is what the
solution has to look like and we can
take this and plug it in to this
equation this vector of responses is
some vector of amplitudes times say
cosine Omega t minus T and just plug
that into this set of matrix equations
note that X double dot is just a you get
minus Omega squared a cosine Omega T and
we now substitute these in to here
you get minus Omega squared for the
first term minus Omega squared times the
mass matrix a cosine Omega t minus V
Plus this stiffness matrix a I better
consistent notation here excuse me a
cosine Omega t minus V and all that's
equal to zero so this these go away and
cancel them out and we can factor out
this a quantity and we get minus Omega
squared M plus K times a equals zero
so you do this with any linearize and
degree freedom system that you know has
a vibration solution to it these are the
unknown mode shapes and so in order to
satisfy this equation either this a has
to be 0 which is a trivial solution
there's no motion no mode shape or
which is this is trivial not too useful
either ASB 0 or the determinant of this
quantity has to be 0
okay
so but the way you do that on a computer
so that would be beginning the way you
would analyze this by hand you find the
determinant of that matrix and it will
be if it is a second if it's a two
degree freedom system you get an
equation in omega to the fourth which
has two roots for Omega square if it's a
three degree freedom system you'll get
an equation and make it to the sixth
when you write out that determinant and
it has three roots for Omega squared and
in degree of freedom system has an
equation that's to order to n Omega to
the to nth power and it'll have n
solutions or roots for the natural
frequency for Omega squared but that
would be if you're trying to grind this
out by hand the way you do this on a
computer maybe I get a little bit more
on here
come back here
so I'll go back to the earlier form I
had here plus K a equals zero now I'm
going to multiply by M inverse so if I
take if I multiply if I invert the mass
matrix if I multiply the matrix by its
inverse what do you get if I multiply M
times M inverse you get a unit matrix
right it has ones on the diagonal so I'm
going to multiply through here by this
and so this gives me a minus Omega
squared and M times M inverse gives me
the unit matrix ones on the diagonal
times a plus M inverse times K a equals
zero and this product is just a matrix
product M inverse times K and I'm going
to call it the a matrix and I'm going to
move this to the other side so I have a
I have a linear algebra expression of
the form a times the vector equals Omega
squared times the unit matrix times a
and I could I could go ahead and
multiply multiply this out for example
this times that I'll get a vector so
this just looks like Omega squared a if
you multiply it out a vector times the
matrix is a vector on the left side a
vector times a matrix gives B back of
Ector it's just the unit but it's just
the unit matrix so it gives me back the
vector times Omega squared
is in what is known as standard
eigenvalue formulation this is standard
eigenvalue problem now it's a problem of
the form a times a vector equals
something a lambda times a a parameter
which we know happens to be the
frequency squared but this is standard
eigenvalue formulation ah good mega
squared a so a times the unit vector you
get some a back as a vector and I got
the Omega squared in front of it and
oftentimes in you know manual for MATLAB
or something they'll describe this as is
some some parameter it's a constant
times a and this is standard what they
call eigenvalue formulation and in
MATLAB in MATLAB if you say for example
e equals AG of a this will return this
returns a vector which is the natural
frequency squared it will return these
lambdas in the first one is Omega one
squared down to Omega N squared and if
you go with this function if you go a
little further if you say V comma D is
AG a then this produces it gives you two
it gives you two matrices back it gives
you V and V is a matrix which it's
columns are the mode shapes so a 1 to a
n this is mode 1 over to a 1
to a n promote n gives you two matrices
one that's that and another one a D
matrix which has the Omega as the
lambdas lambda one lambda in on the
diagonals and it's a diagonal matrix so
it gives you two great matrices back
ones and has the eigenvectors the mode
shapes and another matrix whose diagonal
elements are the natural frequency
squared and that's that's all there is
dollars to with it I cooked without if
you do this numerically and there's lots
of there's different program lots of
different programs there's multiple ways
of doing this in MATLAB when you do it
this way it doesn't come out sometimes
nicely ordered and what I call
normalized but it does produce the
eigenvalues are called eigen values and
eigen vectors the eigen values of the
net are the lambdas the natural
frequency squared and the eigenvectors
are these mode shapes that go with each
natural frequency once you know the
natural frequencies and mode shapes now
we want to get back to talking about
solutions this idea of mode
superposition and if you had given a set
of initial conditions what is the
response how do you add these two modes
together
so we've four let's go back down we'll
return to two degree of freedom systems
like this one to do an example and we
assume that the solution was some a1 a2
cosine Omega t minus a phase angle that
each mode would have this character to
it and I'm going to I'm going to
normalize my mode shapes
so for each mode shape of the system so
this is could be for mode one this is
the mode shape for mode one this is
natural frequency one and a phase angle
one each mode shape I could write I
could write this then as I could factor
out an a the a one pull out a 1 divided
by a 1 so this is going to be written as
a 1 times 1 + a2 over a1 so I just
factored out so for mode 1 its
normalized mode shape by normalized you
just pick some way of stomach in some
way that you repeatedly use you're
consistent in its use I typically type
will say let's make the top element of
the vector one and to make the top one
one you factor out whatever its value is
that you get back from the computer or
from your calculation you factor that
out of every member now you have a
normalized mode shape whose top element
is one there's lots of other
normalization schemes that's just one
way to do it and the
that's one of the mode shapes the total
solution is x1 x2 and this is where the
mode superposition part comes in is some
undetermined constant a 1 times the mode
shape a 2 over a 1 for mode 1 cosine
Omega 1 t minus c1 and I'm going to run
out of room
and now the responses to initial
conditions I'm going to this has got
another term I'm just going to rewrite
it here so we're looking our total
motion response now by mode
superposition will be a1 one a2 over a1
mode one
so the free vibration response of any
two degree of freedom system linear
linearized equation any two degree
freedom linear system can be made up of
the sum of two terms the motion in its
first at its first natural frequency in
its first mode shape and another term
which is the motion at its second
natural frequency in its second mode
shape but now you have two undetermined
constants out here a1 and a2 well where
do you where do they come from they you
got to use your initial conditions to
get those and I'll write down let's see
I got just and maybe enough time to
write this down these are functions of
time so in so a1 and a2 come from the
ICS the initial conditions so at t
equals 0
for example plug in T equals 0 into this
you get cosine fee and over here another
v1 and another way over here cosine of
minus v1 is cosine feet one so you just
put in T equals zero you find out that X
1 at 0 which I'll write x1 0 and x2 of 0
is equal to I'll actually write them out
this is going to be a 1 times 1 cosine V
1 plus a 2 times 1 cosine V 2 and the
second equation that this gives you is a
1 and now to keep from writing these
many
many times I'm going to let this first
a2 over a1 or mode one BR one and the
second one a 2 over a1 for mode 2 I'll
just call it r2 then I can write this
out so this this the second equation
this is r1 cosine B 1 plus a 2 R 2
cosine V 2 and now this I have initial
conditions that are normally given this
would be an initial displacement on 1 an
initial displacement on to the fees I
don't know and the A's I don't know I
have 4 unknowns and two equations how do
I get two more equations I take the
derivative of this expression for to get
velocity I get an a Omega here and an a
Omega here and I plug in T equals zero
and I get two more equations so x1 dot
and X 2 dot equal at T equals 0 this
gives me two more equations and I have a
place to write them for example X 1 dot
or X 10.9 Ischl condition on velocity x2
0 dot this is two equations I would
write I've got time to write down one of
them and you could do the other just the
other four exercise you find this is a 1
Omega 1 sine B 1 plus a 2 Omega 2 sine V
2 and the second equation is you get a 1
R 1 Omega 1 sine B 1 plus a 2 R 2 Omega
2 sine B 2 so these now you have 1 2
then this is initial conditions on
velocity
there's your initial values of velocity
now you have 1 2 3 4 equations in 1 2 3
4 unknowns the a 1 a 2 V 1 V 2 and I
guess I will give you the answer there
you have it once
it's a little tedious but this is sort
of in the spirit of we do two degree
freedom systems so that we can see how
it works and then for four more larger
degrees of freedom systems you do this
with a computer so but the solution for
a one is one over R two minus R one so
all in terms now of things you know
these are two s and our ones are part of
the mode shape and the the other rest is
initial conditions are X 1 0 minus X 2 0
squared plus R 2 V 1 0 minus V 2 0
quantity squared over Omega 1 squared
whole thing square root but now this is
all stuff you know the initial given
initial conditions on velocity given
initial conditions on displacement you
know the natural frequency you know the
pieces of the mode shapes just plug it
in you're going to get a number the
magnitude of a 1 for the given initial
conditions a 2 very similar expression
minus R 1 X 1 0 plus X 2 0 squared
and that's you'd solve for a two and fie
one it's a little simpler minus tangent
inverse B to zero minus r2 v1 zero all
over Omega 1 R 2 X 1 0 minus X 2 0
that's one of the phase angles and the
other phase angle very similar
expression minus tangent inverse minus
r1 v1 zero plus v2 zero like a 2 R 1 X 1
0 minus X 2 0 so just expressions in
terms of all the in terms of the initial
conditions and you can get all four
quantities you can also do this on the
computer but in the few short lectures
that we have we're not going to get into
that but did you show you where it goes
you could do this now they're very
straightforward ways have done it with
matrix algebra on the computer and next
time I'll do maybe it's a quick example
didn't quite get to it today of a
response to initial conditions problem
plug it in there see what happens so but
we're out of time see on Thursday